SEAN LOPP: Thank you all for
taking some time out
of your day to be with us.
Really looking forward to
talking about dashboard fatigue
and how to avoid it.
And then just to reiterate what
Rob said, because it's always
our perennial question, the
recording will be available.
And then we're going to be going
through some slides as well
as some code today.
That's available
already if you want
to go to this link
to follow along.
It's a GitHub repository
that has the slides as well
as the code.
So dashboard fatigue,
what are we talking about?
Before we can address
kind of that question,
we actually need to take
a step back and think
for just a second about what
the goals of a data science team
really are.
And at the end of
the day at RStudio,
we believe that the main
objective of a data science
team is to help organizations
and individuals make
better decisions that
are informed by data.
And so that's a
really admirable goal,
but it comes with its
set of challenges.
And one of the challenges
that we've seen time and time
again is that there's often
a gap between data scientists
and those stakeholders
they're hoping to inform.
And that gap, a lot of
times, is the result
of different mediums.
So data scientists can be
discovering insight, you're
writing code in R, Python,
whereas decision makers often
are spending their time either
in meetings or in their inbox
or perhaps within spreadsheets.
And more and more,
they're doing all of that
if on the go as they
take care of 1,000 things
at once, often on their phone.
And so for data scientists,
data science teams,
we have to find a way
to bridge that gap so
that our analysis can still
be engaging and inform
and ultimately, drive
those decisions.
There's a few different
ways that we've
seen teams kind of close
this gap in practice.
So one way that at
RStudio we're big fans of
is building dashboards.
And so if packages like Shiny
on the R ecosystem or Dash,
for example, on the
Python ecosystem.
You can create these
interactive dashboards
that are more engaging
for those stakeholders.
So they can explore
your analysis,
they can ask questions,
they can kind of
have an understanding
that then allows
them to make better decisions.
So that's one of practical
and very popular way
to close that gap.
Of course, there's
other ways, as well.
A lot of time and
energy has been
spent explaining how
data scientists can put
their models into production.
That often is in
the form of an API
so that other systems
and services can you
help take advantage
of those insights.
And then sometimes,
we might resort
to doing things like modifying
PowerPoint presentations
or you're copying
and pasting results
in kind of more manual ways.
So these are all different
ways that data science schemes
can bridge that
gap between mediums
to make their work more
accessible to decision makers.
But what we've seen is that
sometimes, especially for--
there's really awesome
interesting and exciting
dashboards--
data science teams can fall
victims to their own success.
So what do I mean by that?
Well, a few weeks
ago on Twitter,
Angela Bassa, who leads the
data science team at iRobot--
they make those robotic
vacuum cleaners--
she asked this
question on Twitter.
She said, how do you keep track
of all of your dashboards?
This led to a really
interesting kind of exchange
and I want to show just a few
of the responses that she got.
So one response
is that you could
go about making a dashboard
for the dashboards, so
kind of a meta dashboard.
And this was actually the most
popular response to the thread.
Very kind of data
science way of thinking
about solving this problem.
Maybe I can use the
same hammer that I
used to solve the
original problem
and just make more dashboards.
Another answer, this one I
found pretty interesting,
a lot of teams will create
an index of the work.
Maybe that is a spreadsheet
with links to the dashboards,
maybe it's a page on like,
Confluence or SharePoint.
And of course, the
challenge there
is that you have to
hope that you keep--
you remember keep it updated.
And then I think this answer
was probably the most honest,
which is that a lot of times,
there's not a great response.
That data science
teams can produce
all of these
interesting dashboards,
but there's no great way for
others to interact and keep
track of them.
And ultimately,
this is a problem,
because it kind of impairs
our ability as data scientists
to close that gap and
inform those decisions.
Often, what we'll see is
a really great dashboard
will be created and users
will engage with it once.
But over time, in the coming
days, weeks, and months,
the dashboard falls
by the wayside,
especially if there's
many of these dashboards.
It's just a pretty big burden
to ask for your decision makers
every day to go play
around with the dashboard.
To keep track of
what's going on.
So that creates a
problem for us--
is that if we just wait
for decision makers
to proactively go
visit our work,
we're not actually
closing that gap.
So that's one problem.
We also see something
else kind of interesting
happen as data science
teams try to close this gap.
And so you know one
thing, as we said,
is that maybe the dashboards
fall by the wayside.
Another thing that
can often happen
is that stakeholders
will get excited.
They'll say, great, this
insight makes sense,
can you bring it to my medium.
Can you copy and paste
those predictions
into my spreadsheet.
Or can you send me a
screenshot of that plot
so I can put it in
my presentation.
And that leads to a lot of
painful labor-intensive work.
One of the interesting
things of the last couple
months that I got to work at
home with my wife, who is also
an R user, and one day
looking over her shoulder,
we kind of had this
exchange, where she was doing
exactly what I just described.
She was taking the
results of some R code
and plugging them into a
spreadsheet for her boss.
And me being the R studio fanboy
kind of said, why don't you
create a shiny app?
That'll be really awesome,
it'd save you all this time,
and it could be a big win
for your organization.
And I wish I could have captured
the look on my wife's face.
And her response
here, she basically
said was, like,
my boss, Dave, has
been looking at the
same spreadsheet
every week for years.
Any one who tries
to make changes
gets decimated, basically.
And so she was kind of stuck
in this equally problematic
scenario--
I mean, at least her boss
was engaging with her work--
but it was in a
way that was really
killing her productivity.
We often refer to
these as fire drills
where you have to answer
ad hoc questions that
require a lot of manual
labor-intensive work,
especially on the
formatting side
if you're copying and pasting
results into different mediums.
And so to summarize kind
of the intro here briefly,
data science teams often
and can find themselves
trying to thread this
challenging needle, where
on the one hand, you
might put a lot of effort
into something really
awesome like a dashboard,
only does see that it kind
of falls by the wayside.
On the other hand, you
spend all of your time
kind of in these manual
ad hoc fire drills.
Neither of those are great
ways to in the long run
close that gap between data
scientists and decision makers.
But I'd like to
propose for you today
an alternative
solution that we've
found a lot of success using
ourselves here at RStudio.
So what does this
solution entail?
Instead of creating a
dashboard, what we like to do
is create proactive
notifier or something
that is going to alert
me to the information
that I need to know.
And in our case,
you know, we spend
most of our time
inside of our inboxes,
so that's where our alerts
goes-- is through email.
But we still want to
be able to do that
as data scientists writing code.
And so that's what we're
going to talk about today--
is how you can use a
Rich set of R packages
to allow you to create these
proactive notifications.
And as I mentioned in kind
of with my wife's dilemma,
oftentimes, these
notifications need
to meet the expectations
of our stakeholders
for how they're formatted.
So we'll look at
some new packages
that are available to help you
precisely format these results.
And then finally, we don't want
to solve this dashboard fatigue
problem by introducing
another type of fatigue,
which would be email fatigue.
And so we're going to talk
about how you can only send
these alerts on conditions.
So that instead of
sending emails every day,
you can send emails
more specifically when
there's a problem at hand.
And then finally, we've been
talking a lot about fatigue--
we don't want to introduce email
fatigue, dashboard fatigue.
We also don't want to
introduce data science fatigue.
So we're going to talk
about how we can achieve
these proactive notifications
in an automated way
so that someone doesn't have
to click play every morning.
The picture that
you're seeing here
is one of my favorite
examples of this workflow.
And one of my
roles at RStudio is
to keep track of all the
different R packages that we
build and maintain.
For some of you on
the line, R packages
might be a newer thing.
So briefly, they're just
basically extensions
of the R ecosystem.
They're sort of the bread and
butter of how data science gets
done in R. And they're also--
one of the main
things that we're
responsible for at RStudio
is creating these different R
packages.
And so every day, we go and we
build all of these packages,
and we want to know if
any of those builds fail.
Especially if it's a
really popular package,
we don't want to get a
whole bunch of emails
from users saying,
hey, this package
isn't available or doesn't work.
We kind of want to stay ahead
of those types of problems.
And so what the data scientist
named Greg and I came up
with is this workflow, where
everyday, we run these builds.
And then if there's a
problem, and critically,
only if there's a problem,
we get these types
of targeted emails that tell
me exactly what the problem was
and allow me to then
take further action.
And an example of that
email from my inbox
is what you're
seeing on the screen.
We're not the only ones
who are kind of using
this pattern successfully.
So I just want to tell you a
few quick stories before we
get into the weeds
of writing the code
one of my favorite stories is
from a large infrastructure
as a service provider.
So a company that maintains
thousands, if not hundreds
of thousands of servers.
And what they use
this workflow to do
was track their hardware uptime.
Then if they saw
a problem arising,
they could send a
proactive alert out
to their vendors in the
context of their support level
agreement or SLA.
And what this team was
really excited about is
before adopting this workflow,
they had done this type of task
in Jira.
And anytime they onboarding
a new vendor or they modify
their SLA, they had
to manually click
through a whole bunch
of steps of Jira
to accomplish this task.
The great thing
about this workflow
is that it's all base on
code, so it's really easy
to reuse these different
rules and different R Markdown
documents that are
going to write.
And so this allowed the
team to easily cut down
their onboarding time.
Another really awesome story of
this type of technology applied
was in a high tech manufacturer
people ops department-- so kind
of an HR group.
And they had this
challenging task,
where they needed to
notify division managers
about employee
overtime problems.
So say an employee
worked more overtime
than they were allowed-- they
wanted to send out an alert.
Before they had a dashboard,
and what they found was
there are 30 different division
managers we're not reliably
going to that
dashboard every day
to check if there was problems.
So they adopted this
workflow to instead send out
an email to a manager
only if there was actually
a problem with a specific
employee's over time
submission.
And they actually won
an award of excellence
for adopting this
workflow, which
I think is really exciting,
because it's ultimately
a pretty simple concept that
we're talking about here.
And so if they're able
to win excellence awards,
I think that's going to be
accessible to a lot of teams,
as well.
So let's get into the nuts
and bolts a little bit
to set the stage for Rich,
who's going to walk you
through the code here.
I just want to talk about the
different tools in our tool
belt that are going to allow
us to apply this workflow.
And so the first
thing that I mentioned
is that we're going
to be crafting emails.
And to do that, we're
going to use to R packages.
The first one is R Markdown.
If you're not familiar
with R Markdown,
it's a package that
allows you to combine code
and text to create documents--
beautifully kind of
customizable documents.
And so historically,
R Markdown has
been used to create PDFs
files or HTML files.
But in our case, what we
want to use R Markdown for
is creating the actual
body of an email.
It turns out an email's body
is kind of unique and different
from other types
of output formats.
And so to help kind
of adjust R Markdown
to create the body
of an email, we've
introduced a new
package called Blastula.
And so that's what Blastula
is really good at--
is helping you craft
the body of your email.
We also mentioned
that often, when
you implement these
types of workflows,
you need to format results
in a very specific way.
And because of kind of the
legacy of spreadsheets,
that very specific format
tends to be a table.
And so we're going to spend
a little time walking you
through GT, which is a package
that allows you to have
a lot of control over
the types of tables
that you can produce
from R, and it's also
compatible with
Blastula and R Markdown.
You can embed those tables
right into the email,
like you saw in my example.
So those are kind
of the packages.
And then we get to
what I think is really
the heart of this
whole solution, which
is how we can send these types
of notifications in a more
dynamic way and on a condition.
And the amazing thing
about writing code
is that our answer here for
what can our condition be
is really endless.
With code, the
answer is always yes.
That is really true here.
Your condition
might be something
like anomaly detection.
It might be a complex
model that allows
you to determine dynamic
thresholds with uncertainty
levels.
In our case, it's going to be
just a simple set of rules.
But no matter what it is,
the actual implementation
of sending a notification
on a condition
boils down to a really simple
if statement that I think
is kind of at the heart of how
powerful this workflow can be.
And then finally,
I mentioned you
know we don't want to
introduce data science fatigue,
so we don't want to use
these tools then still end up
in a world where everyday
we have to press Play
on rendering these reports
and sending out these alerts.
And so we're going to talk
a little bit about how
to automate this workflow.
Now there's a lot
of open source ways
that you could go
about doing this.
You could use
something as simple
as Crontab to manage the
execution of these reports.
Or perhaps you could use
a more advanced scheduler,
something like Airflow.
But our case, we're going to
look at RStudio Connect, which
is a professional product
that RStudio kind of sells.
And what RStudio
Connect does really well
is it takes care of some of
the intricacies of putting R
into production.
So you don't have to worry
about the different packages
that your report might need.
You don't have to worry
about login failures,
about authenticating users,
about securely sending email,
or scaling out the system.
So it's a really powerful way to
adopt a lot of these automation
features without having to
reinvent them all yourselves.
So that's what we're
going to show you today.
But the key to all
of this, I think,
is that the code that
we're going to look at
is actually really fun to write.
And that's important, because
doing something that's fun
is obviously a good incentive
to do it in the first place,
but also makes it easier to
share these types of workflows
amongst your organization
and to other people
kind of adopt them, as
well, which is critical
if you want to have a critical
mass around this new type
of workflow.
So to set the stage
here Rich, this
is what we're going to
walk through in our demo.
We're going to start
with some fake data.
And then we're going
to go from that data
to a set of key performance
indicators or KPIs that
are going to serve
as our threshold
for sending alert notifications.
In our case, those are
going to be simple rules.
In your case, that's really
where the data science
magic applies.
And so you might
apply some magic
and give us the benefit
of the doubt here.
And then what we're
going to show you
is kind of a natural first step.
Once we have that
data and those KPIs,
we're going to
build a dashboard.
And don't get me wrong--
the point of today's
webinar is not
to say that dashboards
should go away.
Dashboards serve a
really important purpose
in helping create mutual
understanding between you
and your stakeholders.
It's a great way,
especially in a meeting,
to play around with the
analysis and allow stakeholders
to bring their domain
expertise to the table
and maybe informing what
thresholds or KPI should
be base on their experience.
But it's not a great
place to stop over time.
And so what we're going to do
once we have our dashboard is
show you how pretty much
the same code can be adapted
with the packages I mentioned--
Blastula, R Markdown, and GT--
to create these
automated emails.
Them we're going to put them
into production on RStudio
Connect and show you
the output of what
those emails in an automated
fashion actually look like.
And so with that, I'm
going to go ahead and stop
sharing my screen briefly.
We're going to
switch over to Rich.
Then he's going to walk
you through the code.
RICH IANNONE: Great.
Let me get setup with that.
All right, here we are
in my favorite ITE.
It's RStudio Desktop.
I'm going to walk you through
a few R Markdown files.
And don't worry, all the code
is available on this site right
here.
It's called Beyond
Dashboard Fatigue.
There should be
a link available.
You don't have to furiously
screenshot this code.
It's all there.
The exact same files that are
here are in my ID right now.
So you can relax.
So my goal here is to walk
through the different R
MarkDown files which are
necessary for creating first,
a dashboard, and then creating
the report and email component.
And not dwell too much on the
actual code, except what's
important, but show
you that the structure
and basically, the capabilities
of what could happen.
So then we use our Markdown.
The key is you have
text and yes code--
codes in these chunks here.
You can render this by
hitting the knit button.
I'll do that right now
to show us the dashboard.
So right now, it's
basically working a way
to create a dashboard.
We get this preview window and
here we are with the dashboard.
Really easy.
We just use a little
bit of code here
to create these
panels right here
for all the different parts.
So what I'm doing
this I'm using ggplot
to create a daily users chart.
Same with revenue.
This is our business data.
That's all available
inside of repo, as well.
It's basically fake
data, I made this.
But it's a great
set of some examples
to show us how we can use
email functionality to deliver
a report that's based
on business health.
So that's what I call this.
So these are different KPIs.
And I'll walk you
through that in a second.
But I want to show you that this
is where we're starting from.
We're starting from the
dashboard, which in itself is
great, but you have to
actually look at this data
to know if anything is
alarming with these KPIs.
So that's maybe
not the best thing,
unless you're extremely
diligent with looking
at dashboards, which may
not always be the case.
So let's take that
one step further.
We'll go to a R MarkDown report.
So it's not showing you the
actual code inside these chunks
yet.
I want to see that the
code is essentially
borrowed from the dashboard,
but put into this main report
document.
And same rule applies.
If you want to render this,
you hit the knit button.
And you get a preview
inside of RStudio.
So I'm gonna his this.
And what we'll see is
actually two preview windows,
because we actually
have a sub document here
called business health email.
And that's the email
version of this report.
OK so it'll make more
sense when I hit it.
So I'll do just that.
So we get a rendering here.
And we get two documents here.
So this is the main
report document.
It's supposed to
have lots of details.
We have a gt table right
here, front and foremost.
And we have the same two
ggplot charts here and also
some raw data, as it's a
full blown report here.
And this is actually
the email version,
so it's a bit stripped down.
We don't have the final thing,
like the final raw data.
We just say the full report
is available on Connect,
which it will be.
Check the links
below, because it
generates those links for you.
And the raw data is attached
to CSV file, which isn't here,
but in the final version that
will send out, it will be.
So essentially, this is
a preview of the email.
And it's quite a bit larger.
So we can read it on phones
and smaller displays, which
is great.
But this is what we want to send
out, only if there's a problem.
And we see those problems here,
the cells highlight in red.
So let's have another
look at the code.
I'll walk you through
that and show you
how we get to that point.
OK.
Well, first of all, let's
introduce the packages
that we're using.
We're loading in tidyverse.
That gives us things like dplyr
to bunch our data to transform
it, get it in the right shape.
[INAUDIBLE] dates.
It's very nice.
Then we have GT and Blastula.
So this creates the
table that you saw there.
Blastula helps with emailing.
So we'll use some
Blastula functions
at the end of this document.
And glue is a really
wonderful package for--
it's like an
alternative to paste.
So if you want to make a string,
let's say a custom subject,
quite a bit easier
to use glue and some
variables that you
generated in this document.
So let me show you
the first chunk here.
I'll reveal this.
The first part is essentially
getting your data in,
so get help KPIs.
It's a helper function that's
sourced in from these other R
script files.
And this just gets us
our data to work with.
And in different
circumstances, it
could be pulling
in database data,
it could be pulling in data
from an Excel sheet, whatever.
The idea is just to get
the data into this report.
And then we can apply
other functions.
What we're doing now, is
we're transforming the data.
And then we have a
set of thresholds.
And what we're
doing with that, is
we're saying that
for each these KPIs,
this one is daily active
users, daily active customers.
We have new users, returned
users, and daily revenue,
and a ratio of DAC over DAU.
And we're saying that,
if there's an exceedance,
this will be less
than the threshold
that we set in a different file.
I'll show you that really
quickly right here.
So this could be set
by decision maker.
This will probably be a meeting.
Essentially, this is where the
business health is not so great
if it passes these values.
Essentially, we're saying
that all these ones
should be above these values.
And obviously, you want that
number to be-- lower is better.
So this is our way of saying,
oh yes, OK, we have a problem.
So we're calculating
those right there.
And then what we're
doing here, is
we're getting some
other variables.
And we'll use these later
on to shape the subject
line of our email, to give
us a little more information
upfront, so it's a bit
nicer to digest immediately.
OK.
So we've got some variables.
This is not shown to
the user in the report.
We have a lot of
include equals false.
That means, in the
final report, we
don't actually see this code.
You could reveal the
code, but most of the time
it's not very interesting.
So most of the time we just
hide it with glue equals false.
So I'll show you
this chunk here.
This is where we
make the GT table.
Again, we're not
showing the code.
We're just showing the output
of this, which is the table.
And there's quite a bit here.
Essentially, we
start with the KPIs.
And then we're doing a
few things to the data,
and then we pass into GT.
And then we're doing
things inside the GT API.
We're adding a heading, we're
changing the call labels,
we're using some
helper functions
that we trade in
a different file
to do some JT-related things.
And we're doing some formatting
of numbers and currencies.
And this is quite a bit.
I mean, we can stop
right here at just GT.
And then we have a
pretty good table,
but this essentially,
adds more formatting
and makes the
table really shine.
Again, more
information on this is
available in the GT repository.
I will show that to you.
It's actually just right here.
It's gt dot r studio dot com.
You can learn lots of stuff
about GT through that website.
OK.
So that's a GT table.
ggplot probably needs
no introduction.
That's been around for a very
long time, tons of examples.
We're essentially
reusing the plots
that we had in the
health dashboard
and just putting them here.
We're not showing the code.
We're just showing the figure,
and we're aligning its center
with this option.
And it's the same thing
with the revenue chart,
it's just another
ggplot right there.
OK.
So another key thing
here is the email part.
So if there's a problem
on the last day,
should we send a email or not?
OK.
So here's the
condition right here.
If the total number
exceeds this,
which is to say the
total number of problems
saw in the most recent
day is greater than zero,
so if there are any
problems in other words.
Then we'll prepare this email.
We're going to take
this sub document, which
I'll show you in a second,
which is business health
email dot rmd.
We're going to take that
as the body of the email.
And then we're going to
attach it to a connect email
and we're going to trade
subject line with glue.
So this effort here is
one of our KPIs total
exceed look thresholds.
And then we're having
some more glue code here.
These colored bases
are, essentially,
where the variable total exceed,
which was defined up here,
is being put into the string.
So it's being interpolated
into the string.
It will appear there.
And then here just to continue
the line and we're saying,
these are the names of the
KPIs that have problems.
And then collapse them as
a list separated by commas.
Another cool thing
is, we're actually
generating a csv file
right here, just some data.
And we're attaching
it to the email.
There's attachments argument.
This is really cool, because
we can create any files here.
They won't be seen by the
user in the main [INAUDIBLE]
document, but they can be
attached, which is fantastic.
So this is what will happen.
This email will be sent
if we have any exceedances
or problems.
If we don't, then we
suppress the scheduled email.
It is a bit confusing.
What does this actually mean?
So in Connect, you deploy it
through this, just published
through Connect.
And I'll take you
to Connect, and I'll
show you what this
actually means in context,
which is right here.
OK.
So this is our main document,
our main report in Connect.
So it looks great.
We actually have a history
of these documents.
They'll be published every day.
But to do that, you
have to hit setup.
You actually have to go to
schedule and then schedule
this output to be run every day.
So it'll take all your code,
it'll run it every day,
maybe on different data.
That's kind of the
hope is what happens
is, you'll be connected to
a different data source.
Well, the same data
source, but it will
be updated every single day.
So we'll get different data
and possibly different alerts.
So on this day, we did
have a few problems.
They're outlined here in red.
So that's great.
But we have to
type this every day
to see that there's
a problem, right.
When we send email, we can
send it when there's a problem.
And we don't have
to be checking.
This is almost the same
problem as the dashboard,
having a report here.
But the email of
solves that problem.
So to schedule that,
we schedule every day.
And the key thing is to
send an email after update.
And then we set some recipients.
It could be Sean,
for instance here.
Sorry, we have to go
here first and have
him be as part of the--
on the list.
Sean, great.
Now we can save that.
And now we have this master
list of people that can
view or change this document.
And we can schedule Connect to
send email to those recipients
through here.
So let's do this one more time.
This is kind of cool.
Great.
And we'll save this.
Brilliant.
So every day, it's
going to be run.
And we can change
this, of course.
But this is daily
data, so it makes sense
to send it every day.
And it will send an email
only if the thresholds
were exceeded.
And we can actually
preview the email,
send one to us, yourself,
just to debug the email
and make sure it looks good
before it actually goes out,
before it goes to production.
So I can send this.
And I actually happen
to have one open,
so it shows it to me right here.
This is my email client.
So we can see that
the subject here
is one of our KPIs
in parentheses three.
That's the glue work that
we did here, total exceed,
broke thresholds.
And we have the
list of things here,
which is great,
because if you look
at this in your
list of messages,
you see this right away before
even opening up the email.
And the body looks really good.
This actually looks really
wonderful on a small device,
because the text is quite large.
We have just the
important things,
which are the table, a
little bit of text just
to show what's being shown.
And importantly,
here's attachment.
Here's the csv data in case
it's important for whoever's
looking at the data.
It's right there.
So I want to show you how
you craft this message
body in this business
health email sub-document.
So it's a little bit strange.
When I saw this previously, I
was a little bit weirded out,
because essentially these
chunks have nothing inside them.
What's actually
happening is, is we're
using the chunks in
this main document here.
We don't have to put anything
in as long as the names match
across documents,
all the content
will be transmitted
to the sub-document
and in the email, which
is really very cool.
It reduces typing,
reduces code duplication.
We could have one source of
truth, which is fantastic.
So yeah, we're essentially
adding a section here,
some text, the output, stating
that the full report is
available on Connect.
Check the links below,
because the links
are given here at the bottom.
And these are real live links
that send us to the main report
if you want more details.
And I see that the data is
attached to the cs file, which
is the truth.
It's right here.
So this is really great.
And we're reusing some of
the code that's in the email
as well, this paste.
And this is R Markdown,
so we can use Markdown
with the asterisk
to make things bold.
So yeah, I'm going go back to
his business health R Markdown
document.
And I'll just play
this one more time
in case you missed
it the first round.
If you knit this, you do
to get a preview locally.
So you can debug it before
it even gets to Connect.
There we go.
Yeah.
And again, the strange thing
is we get two previews.
One is the email, which
appears in your browser.
And one is the main report,
which will appear in Connect.
And that's really about it.
I just want to impress upon
you that the main thing is
this very important
bottom chunk.
It relies on having
a Blastula available,
which is the color right here
in this chunk, library Blastula,
because these two functions
are from Blastula,
render Connect email and
attach Connect email.
And as long as you have the
conditions set properly,
we should expect that email
will be suppressed, because it
will be, by default,
sent out every day
unless this condition is--
unless we're going to
the false condition here.
That's about it.
We through it pretty
quickly, but that's
OK, because I want to leave
lots of time open for questions.
And yeah, and what
I'll do now is actually
go to the slides right here.
I'll let Sean finish.
SEAN LOPP: Thanks so much, Rich.
That was awesome.
Hopefully everyone got
a sense for the code
and how easy it is to
write, to implement
these types of workflows.
Lots of questions
that we'll get to
in just a moment that are coming
in, which are all excellent.
Just to quickly recap
in case maybe you
were late and missed a
bit of the introduction,
the goal here is to help
data science teams empower
the really good decisions.
And what we've seen
in our experience,
and what Rich just
showed you, is
that it can help data science
teams do that if they're
able to more proactively
distribute their work instead
of relying on decision
makers to diligently visit
a dashboard on a regular basis.
As Rich also showed,
this workflow
of proactive distribution
is pretty easy to do,
because there's a
rich toolkit of code.
So you can write the code
that you love to use,
even if your decision-makers are
receiving results in the media
that they like.
And then just as a general
rule, the more tools
that we as data scientists
have in our tool belt,
the more likely we are
to be able to impact
decisions in an effective way.
So that's the take home message.
To reiterate, the recording
will be available.
But the slides and
code already are.
So if you want to dive
deeper into what Rich covered
and rerun those examples,
you can certainly do that.
If I go into the
short link there,
that'll bring you to
a GitHub repository
with all the code examples.
So at this point, we have a
pretty fair amount of time
to walk through some of the
questions that have come in.
Rich, I can go ahead and
answer and we can kind of tag
team this.
So one of the first
questions that I
saw that I thought was really
interesting was a question that
asked, what types of things
can you embed in the emails?
So we demonstrated embedding
ggplots and tables.
This particular
participant asked
about interactive hml widgets.
And so Rich, maybe if you could
give a shot at answering that.
RICH IANNONE: Yeah.
Well, it's a little
bit of a letdown,
but not really, because
email clients do not like
any JavaScript in their email.
They tend to strip those away.
So that is kind of out.
The most interactive
you can probably
get is simple HTML elements
and links to see it
in a full featured app, is what
people are doing with email.
So interactive bits
like HTML widgets
are not possible until email
gets beyond where it is now.
Right now, it's very
stripped down because
of the security model of email.
So that's a bummer answer,
but basically don't try it.
SEAN LOPP: Yeah.
A follow on question
was, we think
you showed Apple Mail,
which got some applause
from the audience, Rich.
RICH IANNONE: Oh!
SEAN LOPP: But we'll
throw out there
that the approach has
been validated and tested
on a whole bunch
of email clients.
So for those formats
that are supported,
you'll be able to use Outlook,
Gmail, whatever on your phone
or on a laptop.
RICH IANNONE: I'll
throw it in there
that we made a very large
effort in our QA process
to test as many email
clients as possible,
but arrange sending
types with Blastula
through Connect, just sending
through your own SMTP server,
like via Gmail.
We're actually using a service
called Litmus, which will--
you send them the email
and they will test it
on 50 plus email clients.
And we can see the results
and if things break.
So we were able to
fix a ton of problems.
And more importantly to
ensure that your email will
be delivered without
being mangled,
which is always a good thing.
SEAN LOPP: Awesome.
I'll take another group of
the questions here Rich,
was what if you don't want
to use RStudio connect?
So I can take a stab
at answering that.
The key to all of this,
that's two parts that you
would need to implement.
One is a way to, on a schedule,
render an R Markdown document.
And there's lots of
different ways to do that.
You can use something
like Cron, you
can use something more
sophisticated like Airflow,
or you can manually click
Render on a report every day.
So there's lots
of options there.
The second bit is that you
need to use a service that
will send the rendered email.
And so, Rich mentioned
briefly, and maybe you
can expand upon this,
Rich But Blastula also
has functions for integrating
with non-RStudio Connect email
senders, like an SMTP service.
RICH IANNONE:
Yeah, that's right.
So you can use
Gmail's SMTP service.
You can use Microsoft's
Outlook one, the online one.
And you can also hook up any
of the ones like SMTP2GO,
which is a really nice one.
The problem is, it's
not really viable.
I found Connect is rock solid.
Always sends your emails.
Sometimes you get throttled
with those other services.
So that's a little
bit of uncertainty
you may have to deal with.
But it's possible.
SEAN LOPP: Yeah.
The other thing I'll
add to that, Rich,
that you will want to be
a little bit careful of,
is that when you're sending
these types of notifications,
you just need to watch out
for impersonation issues.
So one of the things that
we've worked hard on Connect
is to make sure that when you
send an email, it's coming,
even though it's an
automated system,
it's coming from a
reputable address
and then going to the people
that are designated to see it.
And so there are some
security ramifications
when you get into the realm
of automating notifications.
You just want to be
careful of if you're
integrating with one of
those other options yourself.
Let's see.
In terms of other
interesting questions,
someone had asked a
pretty interesting one,
which is, do you have to use R?
Or is there a way to incorporate
other languages like Python
into these types of workflows?
RICH IANNONE: I'm
sure there's a way.
But the thing you're missing
is Blastula or training
the email message body.
And Python does have--
I've looked around.
And I've looked for
other Python libraries
that do this sort of
thing, like create a email.
And certainly, you can send
an email great through Python.
But the hard part is
creating the message body.
And the even harder part is
creating the HTML message body,
which is what Blastula does.
So I think it's possible.
You just have to do a
lot of upfront work.
You basically have to
reproduce Blastula in Python
to get that going.
I'd love to find
out if there are
any other packages or sorry--
libraries in Python that
actually do what Blastula does.
But in my search I
couldn't find any.
SEAN LOPP: I'll add
to that, Rich, one way
that you could combine
these two together
is actually within R Markdown.
So it's a bit of a
misnomer, but R Markdown
allows you to combine a whole
bunch different languages.
So while it's an R
Markdown document,
you can certainly have
Python code chunks commingled
with R code chunks, commingled
with bash code chunks,
if you want it, or SQL.
So all those different languages
can live inside the R Markdown
document.
And then R, in that
type of workflow,
just becomes a
facilitator for sending
the email using Rich's
awesome work on Blastula.
RICH IANNONE: Yeah.
I'm glad you brought that
up, because yeah, definitely
all that other stuff,
you can do in R Markdown.
It has a lot of
engines available,
but the last piece
is kind of critical.
SEAN LOPP: So this is an
interesting question, Rich,
on a little bit more
philosophical, I guess.
The person asks, how is
this approach influencing
your thinking around dashboards
and when you would use
a dashboard and
when you wouldn't?
RICH IANNONE: Yeah.
A dashboard, it's
still pretty essential.
But I wouldn't use it as
the way to notify people
of the important, because it
involves diligence and seeing
the dashboards
daily, or whichever
frequency is required to be
ahead of important issues.
So a dashboard is part
of the whole thing,
like you can go to a dashboard
once you get notified,
and then get the history of
what led to certain problems up
to the present day or whatever.
It's not a replacement
for dashboard.
It's basically adds to the
whole stack of analytics.
SEAN LOPP: One thing I'll
echo there that also addresses
another question
that was asked, we
touched on this very briefly.
But a common pattern in
those emails that you said,
is to dynamically generate
a link back to a dashboard.
And so something that
we do a lot at RStudio,
and the example I
mentioned at the beginning,
I'll get an email
that says, hey,
these packages failed to build.
And then it includes
a link to a dashboard
where I can explore the
error codes and the duration
of the job and all sorts of
more interactive questions.
So dashboards aren't
out of the picture.
They just, as Rich that,
aren't the mechanism
for doing the notification.
RICH IANNONE: Yeah.
Exactly.
SEAN LOPP: There
was a question here.
Instead of hard
coding the thresholds,
they can be dynamic, right?
Yes.
RICH IANNONE: Absolutely.
SEAN LOPP: Of course.
RICH IANNONE: This is
basically your code.
I just basically whipped
something up together,
very unsophisticated,
whether it's below or above,
you can definitely pull in
data, generate the thresholds
dynamically, compare.
There's lots of ways to do this.
You can use packages
like anomaly detection,
or you can use the forecast
package to do certain things.
Essentially, what you want to
do is you want to get to a place
where you can make a final
decision on whether to send
the email or not and then
what to put in that email.
And you may have different
versions of email.
You may select between
different types,
or you may be more sophisticated
in the dynamic content you
include like the subject line
or even the content of email,
because the variables
are transmitted
from the main document to
the sub document, which
is kind of cool.
So yeah.
Basically, because this is code,
you can do whatever you want.
You can go nuts, essentially.
SEAN LOPP: Yeah.
A kind of follow on question
was, maybe as a data scientist,
I don't know the
triggers or thresholds.
And so the question
was, does it always
fall on the data science
team to set them?
Or is there some
way for decision
makers to influence
the thresholds?
RICH IANNONE: Yeah.
That sort of thing, I think it's
a conversation between the data
team and the decision makers in
their organization, for sure.
You make a set of
of recommendations.
You base change them on a weekly
basis or some other frequency.
They may be dynamic.
They may just be a system
which creates thresholds
if values are changing fast and
there's seasonality or things
like that.
So it really depends
on your organization
but essentially, it should
be transparent, I think,
because decision makers are
getting the notification.
They probably should know why.
Yeah.
Basically, it's a conversation.
SEAN LOPP: Yep.
And the nice thing about code
is that it's not a black box.
It's very inspectable,
and it gives you
the full flexibility there.
So you're not locked in.
It's not like R Studio's
deciding what the threshold
should be for you.
You get all the options there.
RICH IANNONE: Yeah.
SEAN LOPP: And
that kind of leads
to another question that
came up that I thought
was really awesome.
We talked a lot in this webinar
about creating notifications
to bridge the gap between the
data scientists and decision
makers, but this person
asked, could the same workflow
apply to notify the data science
team of data quality issues?
Absolutely.
RICH IANNONE: Yeah.
Yeah, definitely.
Yeah.
I mean, it's totally up to you
who the email's directed to.
I would set up diagnostic emails
to yourself, if important.
If certain data is suspect
based on some data validation
rules that you have.
I would want to know about it.
And then I would want
to have the engineering
know about it too, to get
to the root cause of things.
So absolutely, yeah.
Definitely send yourself
these notifications.
Yeah.
That's my pitch.
SEAN LOPP: So those were
some high level questions.
There's a few more in
the weeds questions
that we'll address
here at the end.
One of them is from someone
who's already playing around
with the code.
So kudos to you.
And they've hit
a stumbling block
that is maybe a little
bit common as you're
learning this workflow.
And rather than reading
the question verbatim,
Rich, I'll basically diagnose
it and maybe you could even
show the workflow here.
But essentially,
what they did was
they rendered the child document
instead of the main document.
RICH IANNONE: Ah.
SEAN LOPP: So can you talk a
little bit about which document
to render and where?
RICH IANNONE: Yeah.
So this is a trap
I always fall into,
because it doesn't stop you from
rendering the child document.
So it's always
the main document.
So if you render
the child document,
nothing good comes from that.
Yeah.
There should probably
be a warning somewhere,
but there's nowhere to put it.
But essentially, it all
comes from the main document.
And that gives you two previews.
So basically, the thing
you want to ask yourself
is, am I seeing two previews?
And if not, I probably
did something wrong.
So always hit knit on the main
document, and then you'll A-OK.
Otherwise, it won't
harm anything,
it just won't give
you anything useful.
It'll probably just give
you something not great.
SEAN LOPP: Yeah.
The error messages
that you'll tend
to see if you accidentally
that the child document are
that variables are undefined.
And that's because
those variables are
defined in your main document.
RICH IANNONE: That's right.
SEAN LOPP: Now, of course you
could duplicate all of the code
into the child document to have
a child document that's also
standalone, but then you've
needlessly copied and pasted
code, which is something that
we're always trying to avoid.
RICH IANNONE: Yeah.
Try to keep dry, even in your
email message bodies or your R
Markdown documents.
So people that know what dry
means, don't repeat yourself.
Try as much as possible to
have one place for code.
And that's the great thing
about these sub-documents,
taking results from
the main document.
You don't have to
re-write code and worry
about being in sync with
between the documents.
SEAN LOPP: Excellent.
And then, just for the
sake of being in the weeds
with our audience here, maybe
one final question for you,
Rich.
This one was related to GT,
which we spoke on briefly.
And they said, how would
you apply the same row
rules across multiple columns?
And maybe you can just use
this as an opportunity, Rich,
to speak a little bit more
towards what the philosophy is
behind writing GT code and
doing the types of highlighting
that you demo-ed today.
RICH IANNONE: Yeah.
Basically, what you're
doing with highlighting
is you're using tab
style, and you're
specifying either the whole
row, the whole column,
or an individual cell with
the locations argument.
So it's basically like
you're on an Excel sheet,
and you're clicking
something to highlight it,
and then you're doing
this bit of styling, which
could be changing
the text, changing
the background of
the cell, whatever.
How I would apply
the same thing,
I would just use
the columns argument
and specify multiple
columns within bars.
That's how you normally do that.
I would try that first.
If it doesn't work, then
it might be something
with a little bit more to it.
And if the question
is super important,
I would definitely ask
it in RStudio Community
or even inside the GT issues
page in the repository.
SEAN LOPP: Excellent.
Yeah.
So I think that's a
good stopping point.
It allows us a chance to
echo a couple of things.
So one is, thank you, both for
spending your time listening
to us, but also for these
excellent and engaging
questions.
If we didn't get a chance
to answer your question,
the best place to go is
the RStudio community.
And there'll be a follow up
thread that is available to you
specifically to ask
questions on this webinar.
So that's a good way to
continue the conversation.
There was some
questions we didn't
get to address specific
to RStudio Connect.
If you're an RStudio
customer, you
can reach out to your
customer success team.
If you're not, we'd
love to talk to you
about what problems
you're trying to solve
and how we can maybe
facilitate those.
The packages in
code and recording
will be made available.
And again, we just really
appreciate your time
and hope that this type
of dynamic notification
can help you as data
scientists or decision makers,
ultimately at the
end of the day,
make more informed decisions,
which is what we're all after.